[Music]
[Music]
the Umbrella Academy has just dropped on
Netflix and the show expertly captures
the source material in several ways that
make it a thrilling journey from
beginning to end but who are the
Umbrella Academy and what does the
show's ending mean for the cast of
characters going forward well throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the show as well as its ending make sure
you stick around until the end for my
predictions on season 2 as well as my
review of the entire run there will of
course be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything about the
Umbrella Academy then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to the Umbrella Academy is adapted
from The Dark Horse comic of the same
name from Gerard Way similar to the
source material we follow a group of
unwitting superheroes at left to deal
with the upcoming apocalypse after a
group of forty three women mysteriously
fall pregnant without the babies ever
being conceived Sir Reginald Hargreaves
adopts a group of them and trains them
to become superheroes the training is
pretty grueling and brutal and due to it
the casts become very dysfunctional and
not really the types of personalities
that you would expect to become
superheroes the heroes themselves were
numbered from 1 to 7 by Hargreaves which
kind of hints at exactly just how much
he objectified them he really sees them
as weapons that you will use to save the
world and because of this it just
basically destroys their personalities
the characters themselves of course
don't want to be labeled as just numbers
so they begin to carve out their own
identities number 1 for space boy as he
prefers to be called is the leader of
the team he's a strong man archetype
possessing super-strength and he's the
real driving force behind them after
being heavily damaged the character is
injected with a serum that turns him to
a gorilla like Hulk of a man and that's
sort of the reason why he moves to the
moon if space boy is Superman then
number 2 the Kraken is definite
Batman this dark and brooding figure is
an expert in hand-to-hand combat and is
sort of a badass that's definitely my
favorite of the bunch number three is
the rumor and she's very much your skull
at which archetype that can alter
reality by lying about it and few to
this as she's one of the most dangerous
of the group she became a celebrity but
through this lost her child and husband
and you kind of get the feeling that she
deeply regrets having the power that she
does
number four is the seance a character
cursed with the ability to talk to the
dead and because of this he spends the
majority of his time trying to be as
zoned out as possible number five is a
time traveler that's stuck in the body
of his younger self and he's the real
driving force behind the family that
brings them together after warning them
of the coming apocalypse he disappeared
for years and due to this they all
separated so his return kind of becomes
the glue that mends there number six is
dead and number seven
fannia played by Ellen Page has been
ostracized by the family after writing a
tell-all book on just how bad her
childhood was now under the show's plot
and ending which is a hell of a lot of
fun Sonia is an expert violinist and the
first season really focuses on how her
ostracization as a child led to her
eventually becoming a super villain
known as the white whale while she's
labeled as super ordinary we quickly see
through gunz's of a childhood that this
isn't the case she makes mincemeat of
her nannies and more and this really
puts the fear into hargreaves imagine
the dark phoenix times ten with a talent
for tunes and a huge chip on his
shoulder and he kind of understand her
arc as well as why Hargreaves realized
that she was too powerful to let loose
world ifs of course is it revealed till
the later episodes but early on we get
several hints that this may be the case
episode 1 opens with the death of sir
Hargreaves and the team are United at
his funeral after news of it breaks
across the world we get the impression
early on that one by one the Academy
left their childhood home through
Barry's means and it seems like all of
them are mentally scarred for a number
of reasons when number 5 returns and
warns of the apocalypse you really get
the feeling that in attempting to divert
it they in fact caused it
Vanya's slowly uncovers her past and
learns that she was put on pills by
Hargreaves in order to quell her
abilities after he feared that she
wasn't strong enough to control them all
Vanya ever wanted to do was be loved and
eventually this suppression led to her
rediscovering her daughter side after
almost killing Alison she goes on a path
led by fear and manipulation of those
around her with tempte shout her down
and claim that she is ordinary but this
backfires massively eventually after
murdering her friend Harold Jenkins
bania goes on the run and the group
discovered his body number five has been
carrying around an eye for the majority
of the show and after realizing it fits
the victim clay mistakingly believed
that they may have stopped the
apocalypse however this is quickly
rumbled when Alison awakens and reveals
about Vanya's abilities this is
Hargreaves his final secret which is
confirmed by Fogle
unfortunately Alison can't talk anymore
so her powers are no longer able to stop
man yet like all great super villains
she has a real duality to her and it's
clear that his spiral out of control is
full of remorse when we see her
breakdown over Alison's admission that
she wasn't really there for her upon
returning home she's betrayed by
spaceboy who makes her lose
consciousness and locks her in a cell at
Hargreaves at belt a container within
she finally breaks and decides that she
won't be pushed around anymore
and embraces who she is it's a real
tragedy as had the family not alienated
her and she probably would have grown up
to be someone who could change
for the better but instead she becomes
its ultimate enemy she breaks out the
cell and as we head into a finale she
finally stepped into the role of the
white violin walking through the house
she recounts all of the unhappy memories
of her childhood and it's one of the
best realizations of a supervillain that
I've ever seen bottom scream eventually
she kills Pogo and I dare any of you not
to cry over the best death of a monkey
since Caesar the Academy is destroyed
and she heads out into the world which
is when the rest of the family
regretfully realized that they must take
her down once and for all to stop the
apocalypse they head to her concert
where she plays a beautiful song on her
violin that brings the house down
literally they realized that Vanya's
violin is a lightning rod and that in
stripping her over before she finishes
the song that the world will be saved
they rush her but she catches and
suspends there before beginning to drain
them of their life force a lesson sneaks
up behind her and shooter which is when
a white beam fires from her to the moon
the moon explodes which Hills a giant
meteorite towards the earth and it seems
like the apocalypse hasn't been averted
number five says that using that
time-travel ability they can go back in
time to Banyas childhood and repair the
damage that they did otherwise the
apocalypse will forever play out they
are returned to their younger bodies and
then disappear just before the fire hits
them showing that they have went back in
time going into season two there's a lot
to look forward to as well
season Warner's primarily based upon the
group's first graphic novel apocalypse
sweet so it stands to reason that season
two will be based on its follow-up at
Dallas well so I can imagine that it
will initially be focused on fixing
Banyas childhood I don't think that
there is enough there to sustain this
season which is why I think it would
pick up on other pop or internal Tallis
in that following the events of
apocalypse sweet space war becomes
morbidly obese after her
into a great depression due to the
events of the graphic novel and the
Kraken becomes the leader of the team
the book centers around the
assassination of John F Kennedy and
while I don't want to give too much away
it's a joy to read it's heavily rooted
in time travel and there's a big reveal
that one of the characters has a twin
definitely pick that book up if you want
an amazing read as I actually think that
it's better than the first one due to
its ability to juggle the past present
and more and it just makes for an
outstanding time travel story and now on
to my review well the Umbrella Academy
when created as a comic was originally
crafted to be a deconstruction of the
genre that showcased that people we
idolize may not exactly be happy to be
in that position
naturally the show expertly depicts this
and the 10 episode run perfectly
showcases that with great power comes
great psychological issues these are
guys who've had their moments in the
spotlight and since their fall from
grace have really struggled with
self-esteem issues that this inevitably
leads to similar to the haunting of Hill
House the seasoned beautifully uses the
past and present to paint out just how
damaging events from earlier in our
lives can be and unlike most Netflix
shows no episode feels like it's
needlessly being put there to stretch
out the runtime as a big comic book fan
myself I found a lot to love here and I
think that this really has something for
everyone which makes it a brilliant
watch this is a lot better than the
majority of superhero shows that we have
out now our fingertips and I definitely
recommend that you watch it if you
haven't already
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the Umbrella Academy as well as what
you want to see from it going forward
make sure you leave your review and
theories in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of this week's other big time
travel release happy deathday - which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]